alright hello everyone let's get started
today the topic is causal consistency
and then use the cop system the cop's
paper that we're every day is a case
study for causal consistency so the
setting is actually familiar we're
talking again about big websites that
have data in multiple data centers and
they want to replicate the data in each
of their all their data in each their
data centers have to keep a copy close
to users and for perhaps for fault
tolerance so as usual we have maybe I'll
have three data centers
and you know because we're building big
systems we're going to shard the data
and every data center is going to have
multiple servers with you know maybe all
the keys that start with Z a through all
the custodian corresponding shards of
URLs we've seen this for and you know
the usual goals people have you know
there's many different designs for how
to make this work but you know you
really like reads to be certainly like
reads to be fast because these web
workloads tend to be read dominated and
you know you'd like rights to work and
you'd like to have us as much
consistency as you can so the fast
reasons are interesting because the
clients are typically web browsers so
and there's web going to be some set of
web browsers which all call clients the
clients the storage system but they're
really web browsers talking to a user's
browser some so the typical arrangement
is that the reason these happen locally
and rights might be little more
complicated so one system that fits this
pattern is spanner you remember that a
spanner and spanner rights involved
Paxos that runs across all the data
centers so if you do a write in paxos
maybe a client in a data center needs to
do a write the communication involve
actually need requires taxes maybe
running on one of these servers to talk
to at least a majority of the other data
centers that are replicas so the rights
tend to be a little bit slow but there
consistent in addition Savannah supports
two-phase commit so we had transactions
and the reads are much faster because
the breeze used a true time scheme that
the span of paper described and really
only consulted local we also read the
Facebook memcache new paper which is
another design in this demo pattern the
Facebook memcache key paper there's a
primary site that has the primary set of
my sequel databases so if a client wants
to do a right I suppose the primary side
this data center 3 does to send all
rights to data center 3 and then data
center 3 sends out new information or in
validations to the other data centers
right so actually a little bit expensive
and not unlike spanner on the other hand
all the reads are local when a client
needs to do a bead it could consult a
memcache key server in the local data
center and there's memcachedb sir just
blindingly fast this the people
reporting them a single memcache the
server conserve a million reads per
second which is very fast so again the
Facebook memcache D scheme needs to
involve cross data center of
communication for rights but the reads
are local so the question for today and
the question of the cops papers
answering is whether we can have a
system that allows rights to pursue
purely locally and this from the clients
point of views that the client can talk
to the from once it were right they can
send the right local replica in its own
data center as well as some reads to
just the local replicas and never have
to wait for other data centers never
have to talk to other data centers or
wait for other data centers to do rights
so what we really want is a system that
can have local reads and local rights
that's the big that's the big goal
really a performance goal this would
help for performance of course cuz now
unlike spanner and Facebook paper we had
a purely local rights be much faster
from the clients point of view um it
might also help with fault tolerance
robustness if rights can be done locally
then we don't have to worry about
whether other data centers are up or
whether we can talk to them quickly
because the clients don't need to wait
for them so we're gonna be looking for
systems that have this this level of
performance and in the end we're gonna
let the consistency model you know cuz
we're going to be worried about
consistency if you only do the rights
initially to the local replicas you know
what about other data centers replicas
data so we'll certainly be worried about
consistency
but the attitude for this lecture at
least is that we're gonna let the
consistency trail along behind the
performance you know once we figure out
how to get good performance will well
then sort of figure out how to define
consistency in think about whether it's
good enough okay so that's the overall
strategy I'm gonna actually talk about
two strawman designs to sort of okay but
not great designs on the way to before
we actually talk about how cops works so
first i want to talk about a simplest
design that follows this local rating
strategy that I can think of I'll call
this straw man 1 so in straw and one
we're going to have three data centers
and let's just assume that the data is
charted two ways in each of them so he's
from maybe ATM and keys from embassy
shard it the same way in each of the
data centers and the clients will read
locally and if a client writes so
supposing a client needs to write it key
that starts with M the clients gonna
send a write of key M to the shard
server the local shard server that has
its responsible he's starting with M
that shard server would return reply to
the client immediately saying oh yes I
did you're right but in addition each
server will maintain a queue of
outstanding rights that have been sent
to it recently got clients that it needs
to send to other data centers and it
will stream these rights asynchronously
in the background to the corresponding
servers in the other data center so
after applying to the client our shard
server here will send a copy of the
clients right to each of the other data
setups and you know those rights go
through the network maybe they take a
long time eventually they're gonna
arrive at the target data set the other
data centers and each of those shard
servers will then apply the right to its
local table of data so this is a design
that has very good performance right the
reason rights are all done locally may
never have two clients never have to
wait there's a lot of parallelism
because you know this shard server for a
and the shirts are for a more
opportunity independently if the shard
server for a gets right you know it has
to push its data to the corresponding
shard servers and other data centers but
it can do those push pushes
independently of other shard service
pushes so there's parallelism both in
serving and and pushing the writes
around if you think about it a little
bit it's this design also essentially
effectively favors reads and the reads
really never have any impact beyond the
local data center the rights though do a
bit of work whenever you do a right you
know the client doesn't have to wait for
it but the shard server then has to push
the rights out to the other data centers
and you know means that new data the
other data center then proceed very
quickly so reads involve less work than
rights and that's appropriate for a read
heavy workload if you are more worried
about rate performance you could imagine
other designs for example you can
imagine design in which reads actually
have to consult multiple data centers
and rights are purely local so you can
imagine a scheme in which you have when
you do a read you actually read the data
from each of the other date the current
copy of the key you want from each of
the other data centers and choose the
one that's most recent perhaps and then
rights are very cheap and breeds are
expensive or you can imagine
combinations of these two strategies
some sort of quorum overlap scheme or
you write a majority and write a
majority at the only a majority of data
centers and meet a majority of data
centers and rely on the overlap and in
fact there are real live systems that
people use in commercially in real
websites that follow much this design so
if you're interested in sort of a real
world version of this you can look up
Amazon's dynamo system or the open
source
Kassandra system
there was much more elaborated than when
I've sketched out here but they follow
the same basic pattern so the usual name
for this kind of scheme is eventual
consistency and the reason for that is
that at least initially if you do a
write other readers and other data
centers are not guaranteed EC or right
but they will someday because you're
pushing out the rights so they'll
eventually see your data there's no
guarantee about order so for example if
I'm a client and I write he's starting
with them and then I write a key
starting with a sure you know M sends
out it's my right to shards of a rim
sends out one right and the server for a
sends out my right for a but you know
these may travel at different speeds or
different routes on the wide area
network and maybe I wrote maybe the
client wrote em first and then a but
maybe if they for a arrives first and
then the update for am and maybe I
arrive at the opposite order at the
other datacenter so different clients
are gonna observe updates in different
orders so there's you know no order
guarantee
the sense the sort of ultimate meaning
eventual consistency is that if things
settle down and people stop writing and
all of these write messages finally
arrive at their destinations are
processed then I'm an eventually an
eventually consistent system ought to
end up with the same value stored at all
of the all of the replicas that's the
sense of which it's eventually
consistent if you wait for the dust to
settle you're gonna end up with
everybody having the same data and
that's a pretty weak spec that's a very
weak spec but you know because it's a
loose spec there's a lot of freedom in
the implementation and a lot of
opportunities to get good performance
because the system basically doesn't
require you to instantly do anything or
to observe any ordering rules it's quite
different from most of the consistency
schemes we've seen so far again as I
mentioned it's used in deployed systems
eventual consistency is but it can be
quite tricky for application programmers
so let me sketch out a an example of
something you might want to do in a web
and the website where you would have to
be pretty careful you might be surprised
if this is an eventual consistency app
example suppose we're building a website
that stores photos and every user has a
you know set of photo photos stored as
you know key value pairs with some sort
of unique ID is the key and every user
has a list of maintains a list of their
public photos that they allow other
people to see so supposing I take a
photograph and I want to insert it into
this system or you know I human contact
the web server and the web server runs
code that's gonna insert my photo into
the storage system and then add a
reference to my photo to my photo list
so maybe
run maybe this happens we'll say it
happens on clients c1 which is the web
server I'm talking to and maybe but the
code looks like is there's a code calls
the put operation for my photo
and it really should be a keen about you
I'm just gonna candidates just a few
plus value so I insert my photograph and
then when this put finishes then I I add
the photo to my list
right that's what my my clients code
looks like somebody else is looking at
my photographs loosely gonna look fetch
a copy of my list of photos and then
they're gonna look at the photos that
are on the list so client to maybe calls
get for my list and then looks down the
list and then calls get on that photo
maybe they see the photo I just uploaded
it on the list
and they're gonna do a get it for the
you know key for that photo yeah so this
is like totally straightforward code
looks like it ought to work but in an
eventually consistent system it's not
necessarily going to work and the
problem is that these two puts even
though the client did them in such an
obvious order first insert the photo and
then add a reference to that photo to my
list of photos the fact is that in this
event early consistent scheme that I
outlined this second put could arrive at
other data centers before the first put
so this other client if it's reading at
a different data center might see the
updated list with my new photo in it but
when that other client and another data
center goes to fetch the photo that's in
the list this photo may not exist yet
because the first right may not have
arrived over the wife of the client
Tuesday's so if this is just gonna be
routine occurrence in an eventually
consistent system if we don't sort of
think of anything more clever this kind
of behavior where it sort of looks like
the code out of work you know at some
intuitive level but when you actually go
and read the spec for the system which
is to say no guarantees you realize that
ah you know this obviously this correct
looking code may totally not do it I
think it's going to do these are often
called anomalies and
you know the way to think about it is
not necessarily that this behavior you
know you saw the list third on a list
but the photo didn't exist yet it's not
an error it's not incorrect because
after all the system never guaranteed
that this food was gonna do that it's
gonna actually yield the photo here so
it's not that it's incorrect it's just
that it's weaker than you might have
hoped so it's still possible to program
such a system and people do it all the
time and there's a whole lot of tricks
you can use for example you know a
defensive programmer might observe
programmer might might write code
knowing that well if you say something I
mean list it may not really exist yet
and so if you see a reference to a photo
in the list you get a photograph that's
not there you just retry just wait a
little bit and retry because by and by
the photo will probably show up and if
it doesn't we'll just skip it and don't
display it to the user so it's totally
possible to program in this style but we
could definitely hope for behavior from
the storage system that's more intuitive
than this that would make the
programmers lie life easier sort of we
could imagine systems that have fewer
anomalies then yes very simple
eventually consistent system okay before
I go on to talking about how to maybe
make the consistency a little bit better
I want to discuss something important I
left out about this current eventual
consistency system and that's how to
decide on which right is most recent so
for some data if data might ever be
written by more than one party there's
the possibility that we might have to
decide which data item is newer so
suppose we have some key or call okay
and to rights for it you know to clients
launch rates for K so when client writes
a value one another client writes a
value of two we need to set up a system
so that all three data centers agree on
what the final value of key K is because
after all we're at least guaranteeing
eventual consistency when the dust
settles all the data centers all have
the same data so you know data center
three is gonna get these two rights and
it's gonna pick one of them as the final
value for K well of course um datacenter
- sees the same rights right it sees its
own right so they're all seeing this
pair breaks and they all had better make
the same decision about which one that'd
be the final value regardless and the
order that they arrived in right because
we don't know you know the data center
three may observe these to arrive in one
order and some other data center may
observe them to arrive in a different
order we can't just accept the second
one and have that be the final value
meet a more robust scheme for deciding
what the final the most recent value is
for a key so we're gonna need some
notion of version numbers and the the
most straightforward way to sign version
numbers is to use the wall clock time so
so why not wall clock time and the idea
is that when a what a client generates a
put either it or the shard server the
local chart server talks to will look at
the current time oh it's you know it's
125 right now and it'll sort of
associate that time as a version number
on its version of the key so then we'd
annotate these these write messages
these actually both store the timestamp
in the database and annotate these write
messages sent between data centers with
the time so you know maybe this one was
written at 102 and this right occurred
at 103
and so if if 102 writer or suppose the
one of three right arrives first then
the data center three will put in its
database this key and the timestamp one
two three
and when the right for 102 arrives the
standard Center will say oh actually
that's an older right I'm just gonna
ignore this right because it has a lower
timestamp and the time step I already
have and of course if they arrive and
the other order did a sentence we would
have actually stored this right briefly
until the right with the higher
timestamp arrived but then it would
replace it I mean since everybody sees
it some time stamps at least you know
when they finally receive whatever all
these great messages over the Internet
they're all gonna end up with the
databases that have the highest numbered
values okay so this almost works and
there's two there's two little problems
with it one is that the two data centers
if they do writes at the same time may
actually assign this little time stamp
this is relatively easy to solve and the
way it's typically done is the time
stamps are actually pairs of time or
whatever and the High bits essentially
hand some sort of identifier could
actually be almost anything as long as
it's unique some sort of identifier like
the data center name or ID or something
in the low bits just to cause all pipe
signs from different data centers or
different servers to be you want and
then if two rights ride with the same
time in them from different data centers
are gonna have different low bits and
these little bits will be used to
disambiguate which of the two right says
is the lower timestamp and therefore
should yield to the other with the
higher okay so we're gonna stick some
sort of ID in the bottom bits and the
paper actually talks about doing this
it's very common the other problem is
that this system works okay if all of
the data centers are exactly
synchronized in time and this is
something a spanner paper stressed a
great length so if the clocks on all the
servers that all the data centers agree
and this is gonna this is gonna be okay
but if the clocks are off by seconds or
maybe even minutes then we have a
serious problem here one not so
important problem is that rights that
come earlier in time you know that
should be overwritten by later right so
it could be the rights that came earlier
in real time are because the clocks are
on are assigned high time stamps and
therefore not superseded by rights that
came later in time now we never made any
guarantees about this ID eventual
consistency and we never said oh rights
that come later in time we're gonna win
over rightfully the clients nevertheless
we don't want to be already weak enough
consistency we don't want to have it
have needlessly
strange behavior like users really well
notice they eat something and then they
updated later doesn't seem to take
effect because the earlier update was
assigned two times thinks it's too large
in addition if some servers clock is too
high and it doesn't right you know if
it's caucus say a minute fast then it'll
be a whole minute when no other we have
to wait for all the service thoughts to
catch up to the minute fast servers
clock before anybody else can do the
write about heat in order to solve that
problem one way to solve that problem is
this idea called Lamport clocks the
paper talks about this
although the paper doesn't really say
why they use the lamp or clocks I'm
guessing it's at least partially for the
reason I just I don't mind
Flambeau clock is Wade assigned time
stamps that are related to real time but
which hope would this problem at some
servers having clocks that are running
too fast so every server keeps a value
called this T max which is the highest
version number it seems so far from
anywhere else so
so if somebody else is generating
timestamps that are you know ahead of
real-time you know the other servers to
see this timestamps their team axes will
reflect ahead of real time and then when
a server needs to assign a timestamp of
version number to a new put the way it
will do that is it'll take the max of
this team ax plus one and the wall clock
time
the real-time so that means that new
version number so this is the version
numbers that we need to accompany the
values in our venturi consistent system
so each new version number is going to
be higher than the highest version
number seen so higher than whatever the
last Rite was for example to the data
that we're updating and at least as high
as real-time so if nobody's clock is
ahead this Tmax plus one will probably
actually be smaller than real time and
the time stamp tool end up in real time
if some server has a crazy clock that's
too fast then that will cause all other
servers all the ones it's updates
advanced the team axes so that when they
allocate new version numbers higher than
the version number of whatever ladies
rate they saw from the server whose
clock is too fast okay so this is
Lampert clocks and this is how the paper
assigns version numbers come up all the
time in distributed systems alright so
another problem I want to bring up about
our eventually consistent system is the
problem of what to do about concurrent
rates to the same key it's actually even
worse the possibility that concurrent
rates might carry might both carry
important information that ought to be
preserved so for exam a client of both
did both of these you know different
clients client one and client - they
both issue a put to the same key
and both of these let's get sent it to
datacenter 3 the question is what's a
data center 3 do about the information
here and the information here this is a
real puzzle actually there's not a good
answer
the what the paper uses is the last
Raider wins that is datacenter 3 he's
gonna look at the version number that is
signed here and the version number is
assigned here one of them will be higher
slightly later in time data center ID
and a little bit higher or something I'm
a datacenter 3 you will simply throw
away the data with the lower timestamp
and accept the data with the higher
pants that stampin and that's it so it's
using this last Raider wins policy and
in that has the virtue that it's
deterministic and everybody's gonna get
the same answer you can think of
examples in which it's people so you
know for example supposing what these
puts are trying to do is increment a
counter so these clients both saw near
the counter with value 10 they both had
one and maybe we've put 11 right and but
you know what we really wanted to do is
have them both increment the counter and
have it had value 12
so in that case last Raider wins is
really not that great what we really
would have wanted was for datacenter 3
to sort of combine this increment and
that increment end up with the value of
12 so you know these systems are really
generally powerful enough to do that but
we would like better what we'd really
like is more sophisticated conflict
resolution
you
and the way other systems we've seen saw
this the most powerful system to support
real transactions so instead of instead
of just having put in get it actually
has increment operators that do atomic
transactional increments increments
weren't lost and that's sort of a
transactions of maybe the most powerful
way of doing resolving conflicting
updates we've also seen some systems
that support a notion of mini
transactions where at least on a single
piece of data you can have atomic
operations like atomic increment or
atomic test and set you can also imagine
wanting to have a system that does come
sort of custom conflict resolution so
exposing this value that we're keeping
here is a shopping cart you know with a
bunch of items in it and our user may
because they're running you know two
windows in the wind browser
adds two different items to their
shopping cart from two different web
servers
we'd like these two conflicting writes
to the same shopping cart to resolve
probably by taking set union of the two
shopping carts and ball instead of
throwing one away and accepting the
other I'm bringing this up
satisfying solution indeed the paper
doesn't really propose much of a
solution it's just a drawback of weekly
consistent systems that it's easy to get
into a situation where you might have
conflicting rights to the same data that
you would like to have sophisticated
sort of application specific resolution
to but it's generally quite hard and
it's just like a thorn in people's sides
that has to be lived with typically and
that that goes for both the eventual
consistency my straw man here hand for
the and for the P versus the paper dance
and a couple of paragraphs it it could
be used to do better
they don't really explore that because
it's difficult okay back to eventual
consistency my straw man system if you
recall it had a real problem with even
very simple this very simple scenario I
know we did put a photo and put a photo
list and then somebody else in a
difference and it reads the new this but
when they read the photo they find
there's nothing there so can we do
better can we build a system of it's
still allows local reads and local
rights but is has slightly mini-lesson
Thomas I'm going to propose one that's
strong me into this kind of one step
closer to papers so this is straw man
too
and
in this scheme I'm gonna propose a new
operator not just put and get but also a
sink operator that clients can use and
the sink operator will do will be the
key and a version number and what sink
does when a client calls it is sink
waits until all data centers copies of
key K are at least up to date as of the
specified version number so it's a way
of forcing order the client can say look
I'm gonna wait as well everybody knows
about this value and I wanna only see
after every one everything is Center
knows about this value and in order for
clients to know what version numbers to
to pass the sink we're gonna change the
put call a bit so that you say put key
value and put returns the version number
of the of this updated K you could call
this this sink is asking that acting is
a sort of a barrier offense we could
call this eventual consistency plus
barriers see calls the barrier
I'm gonna talk about how to users in a
moment but just keep in mind this thing
calls likely to be pretty slow because
the natural implementation of it is that
it actually goes out and talks to all
the other data centers and asked them
you know is your version of key pay up
to at least you know this version number
and then have to wait booth for the data
centers to respond and if any of them
say no it's got to then read that data
yes all right so how would you use this
well again for our photo list
now maybe client one that's updating
photos it's going to call put to insert
the photo it's gonna get a version
number now you know the programmer now
has to there's a danger here that update
the photo this but you know what if some
other data center you know hasn't seen
my photo yet so then the programmer is
gonna say sync and you're gonna sink the
photo wait for all data centers to have
that version number that was returned by
put and only after the sync return will
client one call put update update the
photo list and now if client two comes
along I must read the photo list and
then to be in the photo you know who
knows client two is going to do a get of
the photo list let's say time is
passing the same for them it's gonna do
a get at the photo list and if it sees
the photo on that list it'll do a get
you know again in its local data center
of the photo and now we're actually in
much better situation if client to in a
different data center saw the photo in
this list then that means that client
want had already called put on this list
because it's this put that adds the
footage of the list if client wanted
already called put on this list that
means the client one now given the way
this code works right had already called
sink and sink doesn't return until the
photo is present at all data centers so
that means that client two can the
programmer for client two can rely on
well the photos in the list that means
this whoever added the footage to the
list their sync completed and the fact
that this thing completed means the
photo is present everywhere and
therefore we can rely on this get photo
actually returning the photograph ok so
this works and it's actually reasonably
practical it does require fairly careful
thought on the part of the program or
the programmer you know has to think aha
I need a sink here I need to put sink
put in order for things to work out
right the reader for the readers much
faster but the reader still needs to
think oh you know I'm gonna at least
tested that the programmer has to you
know check with it if he's if the
programmer does a get list and then I
get photo from that list that uh you
know verify that indeed the code
modified the list called sink before
adding some things for list that is
quite a bit of thought
with this is all about the sink cause
all about is enforcing order make sure
that this completely finishes before
this happens the readers so that sink
and sort of explicitly forces order for
writers readers also have to think about
order the order is actually obvious in
this example but it is true that if the
writer did put a put then sink and then
put of a second thing then almost always
readers need to read the second thing
and then read the first thing because
guarantees you get out of this out of
this sink scheme these barriers is that
if a reader sees the second piece of
data then they're guaranteed to also see
the first piece of data so that means
the reader sort of need to be the second
piece of data first and then and then
the first item of data okay so there's a
there's a question about fault tolerance
mainly at if one data center goes down
that means the sink blocks until the
other data centers brought up
that's absolutely right so you're
totally correct this is a this is not a
great scheme alright this is sort of a
straw man on the way the cops this sink
called would block the way this actually
that sort of version of this that people
use in the real world to avoid this
problem will you know whatever data
centers down will the sink block forever
is that puts and gets both actually
consult a quorum of data center so that
this a sink will only wait for you know
say a majority year of data centers to
acknowledge that they have the latest
version of the photo and it get will
actually have to consult an overlapping
majority of data centers to in order to
get the data so things are not really
real versions of this are not perhaps as
rosy aasaiya as I may be implying again
the the systems that work in this way is
you're interested it's dynamo
and Cassandra and they use quorums to
avoid the wall talks pop okay okay so
this is a straightforward design and has
decent semantics even though it's slow
and this as you observe not very fault
tolerant the read performance is
outstanding because the reads are still
for local at least if we if the quorum
setup is read one write all and the
write performance is not great but it's
okay if you don't write very much or if
you don't mind great waiting and the
reason why you can maybe convince
yourself that the rate performance is
not a disaster is that after all the
Facebook memcache D paper has to send
all rights through the primary data
center so yeah you know Facebook runs
multiple data centers and clients talk
to all of them but the rates have to all
be sent to the my sequel databases at
the one primary data center
similarly spanner writes have to wait
for a majority of replica sites to
acknowledge the rights before the
clients thought to proceed so the notion
that clients might have dis rule that
the rights might have to wait to talk to
other data centers in order to allow the
reads to be fast is does not appear to
be outrageous in practice mom still I
you know you might like to nevertheless
have a system that does better than this
to somehow have semantics of sync that
sort of or sync is forcing this put
definitely appears to everyone to happen
before the second put you might like to
have that and without the cost so we'll
be interested in systems and this is
starting to get close to what cops does
interested in systems in which instead
of sort of forcing the clients to wait
at this point we somehow just encode the
order as a piece of information that
we're going to tell the readers or tell
the other data centers and a simple
do that which the paper mentions as a
non scalable implementation is that at
each data center so this is a logging
approach at each data center instead of
having the different shard servers talk
to their counterparts in other data
servers sort of independently instead at
every day the center we're gonna have a
designated log server that's in charge
of communicating of sending writes to
the other data center so that means if a
client does it right does it put to its
local shard and that's chart that shard
instead of just sending that the data
out sort of separately to the other data
centers will talk to his local log
server and append the right to the one
log that this data center is
accumulating and then if a client say
does a write to a different key maybe
we're writing key a and key B here
instead of again instead of this shard
server sending the right to key B sort
of independently it's gonna tell the
local log server to append the right to
the log and then the log server send out
their log to the other data centers in
log order so that all data centers are
guaranteed to see the right to a first
and they're gonna hope process that rate
to a first and then all data centers are
going to see our right to B and that
means if a client does a right to a
first and then does it right to be the
writes will show up in that order and it
in its log a and B and they'll be sent
the right to a first and then the right
to be to each of the t's data centers
and they probably actually have to be
sent to a kind of single log receiving
server which plays out the rates one at
a time as they arrive in log order so
this is the logging strategy if the
paper criticizes
it's actually regain some of the
performance we want because now clients
we're no longer we now eliminate the
sinks the clients can go back to this
going put of a and then put B and they
client puts can return as soon as the
data is sitting in the log at the local
log server so now client puts and gets
are now quite fast again
but we're preserving order sort of by
basically through the sequence numbers
of the entries and the logs rather than
by having the clients wait so that's
nice we get the order you know now we're
forcing ordered writes and we're causing
the rights to show up in order at the
other data center so that reading
clients will see them in order and so
our my example application might
actually work them out with this scheme
the drawback that the paper points to
about this style of solution is that the
log server now all the rights have to go
through this one log server and so if we
have a big big database with maybe
hundreds of servers serving at least in
total a reasonably high workload the
right workload all the rights have to go
through this log server and possibly all
the rights have to be played out through
a single receiving log server at the far
end and a single log server as the
system grows there get to be more and
more shards a single log server may stop
being fast enough to process all these
rates and so cops does not follow this
approach to conveying the order
constraints to other data centers
okay so we want to build a system that
can at least from the clients point of
view process rates and reads purely
locally we don't want to have to wait
you don't want clients to wait in order
to get order we want a forward we like
the fact that these rates are being
forward asynchronously but we somehow
want to eliminate the central log server
so we want to somehow convey
order information to other data centers
without having to funnel all our rates
through a single logs alright so now
that brings us to what cops is actually
up to so when I can talk about now is
starting to be what cops does and what
I'm talking about though is the non GTE
version of cops cops without get
transactions ok so the cops is the basic
strategy here is that when cops clients
read and write locally they accumulate
information about the order in which
they're doing things that's a little
more fine-grain than the logging scheme
and that information is sent to the
remote data centers whenever a client
doesn't quote so this we have this
notion of client context and as a client
does get some puts you know maybe a
client as a get of X and then I get it Y
and then a put of Z with some value
the context the library that the client
uses that implements Budhan get is going
to be accumulated in this context
information on the side as the put sand
gets occur so if a client doesn't get
and that yields some value with version
2 I'm just going to save that as an
example maybe get returns the current
value of x and that current value House
version 2 and maybe Y returns the
current value of version for what's
going to be accumulated in the context
is that this client has read X and a got
version 2 then after the get for why the
cops client libraries gonna add to the
context so that it's not just we've read
X and gotten version 2 but also now
we've read Y and gotten version 4 and
when the client does a put the
information that's sent to the local
shard server is not just put key and
what if the value is but also these
dependencies so we're going to tell the
local shard server for Z that this
client has already read before doing the
put X and got version 2 and Y and got
version 4
and you know what's going on here is
that we're telling where the client is
expressing this ordering information
that this put to Z now the client had
seemed X version 2 and Y version 4
before doing the foot so anybody else
who reads this version of Z had also
better be seeing X&Y with the Beasties
versions and similarly if the client
then does a put of something else say Q
what's going to be sent to the local
shard server is not just the Q and this
but also the fact that this client had
previously done some gets input so let's
suppose this put yields version 3 you
know the local shard server says a high
assigned version three to your new value
for Z then when we come to do the quit
of Q is going to be accompanied with
dependency information that says this
put comes after this put of Q comes
after the put of Z that created Z
version three and at least notionally
the rest of the context
ought to be passed as well although
we'll see that for various reasons cops
can optimize away this information and
if there's a proceeding put only sends
the version information for the point so
the question is is it important for the
context to be ordered I don't believe so
I think I think it's sufficient to treat
the context or at least the information
that's sent in the put as just a big bag
of dependencies for at least four
non-transactional cops okay so the
clients are community this context and
basically send the context with each put
and the context is encoding this order
information that in my previous straw
man straw man 2 was sort of forced by
sink instead of doing that we're not
waiting for accompanying these puts with
oh this put needs to come after these
previous values and this put needs to
come after these previous values cops
calls these relationships that this put
needs to come after these previous
values of dependency
and dependency and it writes it as
supposing this foot produces Z version
three we express it as really there's
two actually two dependencies here one
is that X version two comes before Z
version three and the other is that Y
version four comes before Z version
three and these are it's just definition
or notation that the paper uses to talk
about these individual pieces of order
information that cops needs to enforce
alright so so then what is this what is
this dependency information this passed
to the local shard server what does that
actually cause cops to do well eats cops
shard server when it receives a put from
a local client first it assigns the new
version number then it stores the new
value you know it stores for Z this new
value along with the version number that
it long version number that allocated
and then it sends the whole mess to each
of the other data center so at least
some non GT cops the local shard server
only remembers the key value and latest
version number doesn't actually remember
the dependencies and only forwards them
across the network to the other data
centers so now the position were in is
that let's say we had a client produced
a put of Z and some value it was
assigned version number v3 and it had
these dependencies
XV 2 + a YB 4 right and this is sent
from datacenter 1 let's say to the other
data center so we got a datacenter 2 and
datacenter 3 both receive this now in
fact this information is sent from The
Shard server for ze so there's lots of
shard servers but only the shard for Z
is involved in this
so here datacenter 3 the shirts are for
Z is going to receive this put from sent
by the client short server forwards it
this short server the the with this
dependency information that you know X V
2 and Y before come before Z B 3 but
that really means is operationally is
that this new version of Z can't be
revealed to clients until its
dependencies these versions of x and y
have already been revealed to clients in
datacenter 3 so that means that the
shard server visi must hold this right
must delay applying this right to Z
until it knows that these 2 dependencies
are visible in the local data center so
that means that Z has to go off let's
say the you know we have these shard
server for X and the shorts are for Y
Z's gotta actually send a message to the
shard server for X and the shard server
for Y saying you know what's the version
number for a current version for a
number for x and y and has to wait for
the result if both of these shards
servers say oh you know they give a
version number that's 2 or higher or 4
or higher for Y then Z can go ahead and
apply to put to its local table of data
however you know maybe these two shard
servers haven't received the updates
that correspond to version 2 of
extraversion for Y and that KC has to
hold on to this update the shard server
is he has to hold on to this update and
tell
the indicated versions of X or Y ever
actually arrived and been installed on
these two short servers so there may be
some delays now and only after these
dependencies are visible at datacenter 3
only then can the shards of a4z go ahead
and write updated stable for Z to have
version 3 ok and what's what that means
of course is that if a client the
datacenter 3 does a read for Z and sees
version 3 then because he already waited
that means if that client then reads X
or Y it's guaranteed to see at least
version 2 of X and at least version 2 of
Y because he didn't reveal the shards or
didn't reveal Z until it was sure the
dependencies would be visible ok so
question what if x and y never get their
values perhaps due to a network
partition with the Z shard block forever
yeah the um the semantics require the Z
shard to block forever that's absolutely
true so you know there's certainly an
assumption here that well they're you
know two ways that that might turn out
ok one is somebody repairs the network
or repairs whatever was broken and x and
y do eventually get their updates that
be one way to fix this and then z will
finally be able to apply the update
might have to wait a long time the other
possibility is maybe the data center is
entirely destroyed
you mean the building burns down and so
we don't have to worry about this at all
but it does point out a problem that's
real criticism of causal consistency and
that's that these delays can actually be
quite nasty because you can imagine oh
you know Z is waiting for the correct
value for X to arrive you know even if
there's no failures and nothing burns
down even mere slowness can be
irritating Z mate you have to wait for X
to show up well it could be that X has
already showed up and has arrived at
this charts
but it itself had dependencies maybe on
key a and so this chart server can't
install it until the update for a
arrives because X this put of X depended
on some key a and Z still has to wait
for that because what Z's waiting for is
for this version of X to be visible to
client so it has to be installed so if
it's arrived if the update for X is
arrived but itself is waiting for some
other dependency then we may get these
cascading dependency Waits and in real
life actually these you know these
probably would happen and it's one of
the problems that people bring up and
you know against calls are consistency
when when you try to persuade them it's
a good idea this problem of cascading
delays so that's too bad um although on
that note it is true that the authors of
the cops paper have a follow on P
actually a couple of interesting
follow-on papers but one of them has
some mitigations for this cascading
weight problem okay so for a photo
example this is the scheme this cop
scheme will actually solve our photo
example and the reason is that you know
this put we're talking about is the put
for the photo list the dependencies is
gonna have and its dependency list is
the insert of the photo and that means
that when the put for the photo Willis
arrives at the remote site the remote
chard server is essentially going to
wait for the photo to be inserted and
visible before it updates the photo list
so any client in a remote site that is
able to see the new photo of the updated
photo list is guaranteed to be able to
see the photo as well so this cop scheme
fixes the photo and photo list example
this the scheme the cops is implementing
is is usually called causal consistency
so there's a question is it's off to the
programmer to specify the dependencies
no it turns out that though that context
information this context information
that's accumulated here the cops client
library can accumulate it automatically
so the program only does gets and puts
and may not even need to see the version
numbers so simple program we just do
gets inputs and internally the cops
library maintains these contexts and
adds this extra information to the put
our pcs so that the programmer just just
does get some puts and system kind of
automatically tracks the dependency
information so that's very convenient I
mean just a you know pop up a level for
a moment you know we now built a system
that's that is as semantics powerful
enough to make the photo example code
work out correctly to have it sort of
had the expected result instead of
anomalous results and at least arguably
it's reasonably efficient because nobody
was you know the client never has to
wait for rights to complete there's none
of this sink business and also the
communication is mostly independent
there's no central log server so
arguably this is both reasonably high
performance and has reasonably good
semantics reasonably good consistency so
the the consistency that this design
produces is usually called causal
consistency and it's actually a much
older idea than this paper there's been
a bunch of call so consistency schemes
before this paper indeed a bunch of
follow-on work so it's a treating idea
that people like a lot
what causal consistency is what it sort
of means and here I am putting up I
think a copy of figure two from the
paper
the sort of what the definition says is
that the clients actions induce
dependencies so there's two ways that
dependencies are induced one is if a
given client there's a put and then I
get does it get and then a PUD or a put
and then a put then we say that the the
put depends on the previous put or get
so that in this case put of why if two
depends on the put of X of one so that's
one form of dependency another form of
dependency if is if one client frees a
value out of the storage system then we
say that that the get that that second
client issued depends on the
corresponding put that actually inserted
the value from a previous client and
furthermore we say that the dependency
relationship is transitive so that you
know this put depends on that get this
get by client two depends on the put by
client one and by transitivity in
addition we can conclude that the client
two's get depends on client ones gift
and so that means that this last put of
by client three for example depends on
all of these previous operations so
that's a definition of causal dependency
and then a causally consistent system
says that says that if through the
definition of dependency I just outlined
a depends on B sorry B depends on a and
a client reads B then the client must
subsequently also see a the dependency
so if client ever sees through a second
of two ordered operations operations
ordered by dependency and the client is
also then after that guaranteed to be
able to see the everything that that
operation depended
you know so that's the definition and
it's you know in a sense kind of
directly derived from what the system
actually does so this is very nice when
updates are causally related that is if
yeah you know these clients and in some
sense they're talking to each other you
know indirectly through the storage
system and so the clients are I kind of
wear that of you know if we somebody
reads this value and c5 sees five and
inspects the code you know they can
conclude that really really you know
this there's a sense in which this put
definitely must have come before this
last put and so if you see slash but you
really gosh you really just deserve to
see this first put so in that sense
causal consistency gives you this
programmers kind of a sort of well
behaved visas allows them to see well
behave values coming out of the storage
system another thing that's good about
causal consistency is that when it
updates when two values in the system
are not two updates are not causally
related the causal consistency system
you know the cops storage system has no
obligation is about maintaining order
between updates that are not causally
related so for example if I mean that's
good for performance so example if we
have you know client one does a put of X
and then I put Z and then around the
same time client two does a put of why
there's a you know there's no causal
relationship between these and therefore
you know sorry there's no causal
relationship between the put of Y and
any of the actions of client one and so
the cops is allowed to do all the work
associated with the put of Y completely
independently for client ones puts and
the way that plays out is that it's done
and the put of Y is sort of entirely
happens in the servers that for the
shard of why these two puts
are only involve servers for the shards
that X and Z are in it may require some
interaction here because the remote
servers for Z may have to wait for this
put to arrive not but they don't have to
talk to the servers that are in charge
of of Y so if that's a sense in which
causal consistency allows good allows
parallelism and good performance and you
know this is different from potentially
from linearizable systems like Anna
linearizable system the fact that this
put Y came after the put of X in real
time actually imposes some requirements
on the linearizable storage system but
there's no such requirements here for
causal consistency and so you might be
able to build a causal consistency
causally consistent system that's faster
than a linearizable system okay there's
a question would cops gain any more
information by including puts in the
client context okay so it's this may be
a reference to the today's lecture
question it is the case so why don't I
explain the answer for the electric
question the if a client does get of X I
mean look at its context does the get of
X maybe and then put to Y and then a
quit to Z in the context initially is X
version something you know that when we
client since the puts of the server it's
gonna include this context along with it
but in the actual system there's this
optimization that after a put the
context is replaced by simply the
version number for the put and any
previous stuff in the context like
namely this information about X is a
race from the from the clients context
so it only includes after put the
context is just replaced with
number returned from the put that so
isn't this returns you know version
version seven of why and the reason why
this is correct and doesn't lose any
information for the non-transactional
cops is that for this when this put is
sent out to all the remote sites the put
is accompanied by X version whatever in
the dependency list so this put won't be
applied until at all and each data
center until this X is also applied so
then when if the client then does this
put right what this turns into is sent
to other data centers is really a put
with Z and some value and the dependency
is just Y version seven all the other
data centers are going to wait for
they're gonna check before applying Z
they're gonna check that Y version seven
has been applied at their data center
well we know the Y version seven won't
be applied at their data center until X
version whatever is supplied at that
data center so there's sort of a
cascading delays here where that is
telling other data centers to wait for Y
version seven to be installed implies
that they must also already be waiting
for whatever Y version seven depended on
and because of that we don't need to
also include X version the X version and
this dependency list because those data
centers will already be waiting for it
that version of X so the answer the
question is no cops call the
non-transactional cops doesn't need to
have anything doesn't need to remember
the gets in the context after it's done
put
all right a final thing to note about
this scheme is that cops only see
certain relationships it's only aware of
certain causal relationships that is it
only you know cops is aware that if a
single client thread does a put and then
another put client you know cops record
so this the second put depends on the
first book furthermore cops is aware
that oh what a client does a read of a
certain value that it's depending on I'm
the one to put the created that value
and therefore depending on anything that
that depended on so you know cops is
directly aware of these dependencies
here however it could it is often the
case that causality in the larger sense
is conveyed through channels that cops
is not aware of so for example you know
if client one does a put of X and then
the human you know who's controlling
client one calls up client to on the
telephone or it's you know email or
something that says look you know I just
updated the database with some new
information why don't you go look at it
right and then client to you know does
it get of X sort of in a larger sense
causality would you know
suggest the client to really ought to
see the updated X because client to new
from the telephone call that X had been
updated and so if cops had known about
the telephone call it would have
actually included the it would have
actually caused the extra sorry if the
telephone call had been itself a put
right you know it would have been a put
of telephone call here and I get of
telephone call here and if this get had
seen that put cops would know enough to
arrange that this get would see that put
but because cops was totally unaware of
the telephone call there's no reason to
expect that this get would actually
yield the put value so cops is sort of
enforcing causal consistency but only
for the sources the kinds of causation
the cops is directly aware of and that
means that the sense in which cops is
causal consistency sort of eliminates
anomalous behavior well it only
eliminates anomalous behavior if you
restrict your notion of causality to
what cops can see it in the larger sense
you're going to still see odd behavior
you definitely going to see situations
where you know someone believes that a
values been updated and yet they do not
see the updated value that's because
their belief was caused by something
that cops wasn't aware of all right
another potential problem which I'm not
gonna talk about is that the remember
for the photo example with the photo
list there was a particular order of the
adding a photo and that particular
different order of looking at photos
that made the system work with causal
consistency as we're definitely relying
on the there being sort of if the reader
reads the photo list and then reads the
photo in that order that the fact that a
photos refer
joana photo list means that the read of
the photo will succeed it is however the
case that there are situations where no
one order of reading or combination of
orders of reading or writing will cause
sort of the behavior we want and that
but this is leading into transactions
which I'm not gonna have time enough to
explain but at least I want to mention
the problems the paper set up so
supposing we have our photo list and
it's protected by an access control list
and an access control this is basically
a list of usernames that are allowed to
look at the photos on my list
does that means that the software that
implements these photo lists with access
control this needs to be able to you
know read the list and then read the
access control list and see if the user
trying to do the read is in the access
control list and however neither order
of getting the access control list and
the list of photos works out so if the
client code first gets the access
control list and then gets the list of
photos that order actually doesn't
always work so well because supposing my
client Reesie access control list and
sees that I'm on the list but then right
here the owner of this photo this
deletes me from the access control list
and inserts a new photograph that I'm
not supposed to see in the list list
right so c2 does a you know a port of
access control is to delete me and then
a put of the photo list to add a photo
I'm not allowed to see then my client
gets around to the second get it sees
this list you may see this list which is
the now the updated list that has the
photo I'm not allowed to see but my
client thinks aha I'm in the access
control list because it's reading an old
one
and here's this photo so I'm allowed to
see you so in that case you know we're
getting an inconsistent what we know to
be an inconsistent sort of combination
of a new list and an old access control
list but there was really nothing but
but causal consistency allows this it'll
it calls a consistency only says well
you're gonna see data that's at least as
new as the dependencies every time you
do a get so and indeed if you know as
the paper points out if you think it
through it's also not correct for the
reading client to first read the list of
photos and then read the access control
this because sneaking in between this
though this might have a this that I
read may have a photo I'm not allowed to
see and at that time maybe the access
control this didn't include me but at
this point the owner of the list may
delete the private photo add me to the
access control list and then I may see
myself in the list so again if we do it
in this order it's also not right
because we might see we might get an old
list and a new access control list so
causal consistency as I've described it
so far isn't powerful enough to deal
with this situation you know we need
some notion of being able to get a
mutually consistent list and access
control lists through either sort of
both before some update or both after
and cops GT actually provides a way of
doing this it by essentially doing both
Gatz
but but cops GT sends the full set of
dependencies back to the client when it
doesn't get and that means that the
client is submit is in a position to
actually check the dependencies of both
of these return values and see that aha
you know there's a dependency for list
that is a version of these sorry for
that there might be a the dependency
list for the access control list me
mention that it depends on a version of
this that's in the farther ahead than
the version of Lists the
begone and in that case cops GT would be
fetch the data alright with one question
is it related to the threat of execution
yeah so it's true their causal
consistency doesn't really it's not
about wall clock time so it has no
notion of wall clock time there's only
the only sort of forms of order that
it's obeying that are even a little bit
related to walk walk time or that if a
single thread does one thing and then
another and another
then causal consistency does consider
these three operations to be in that
order but it's because one client thread
did these sequence of things and not
because there was a real time
relationship so just a wrap up here to
sort of put this into a kind of larger
world context causal consistency has has
been an is like a very kind of promising
research area and has been for a long
time because it does seem like it might
provide you with good enough consistency
but also opportunities more
opportunities and linearise ability to
get high performance however it hasn't
actually gotten much traction in the
real world
people use eventual consistency systems
and they use strongly consistent systems
but it's very rare to see a deployed
system and as causal consistency and
there's a bunch of reasons potential
reasons for that you know it's always
hard to tell exactly why people do or
don't use some technology for real-world
systems one reason is that it can be
awkward to track per client causality in
the real world a user and browser are
likely to contact different web servers
at different times and that means it's
not enough for a single web server to
keep users context we need some way to
stitch together context for a single
user as they visit different web servers
at the same website so that's painful
I know there is this problem that cops
doesn't doesn't track only tracks causal
dependencies it knows about and that
means it doesn't doesn't have a sort of
ironclad solution or doesn't sort of
provide ironclad causality and only sort
of certain kinds of causality which is
well sort of limits how appealing it is
another is that the you know eventual
and causal consistent systems can
provide only the most limited notion of
transactions and people more and more I
think as time goes on are sort of
wishing that their storage systems had
transactions I'm finally the amount of
overhead required to push around a track
and store all that dependency
information can be quite significant and
you know I was unable to kind of detect
this in the performance section of the
paper but the fact is it's quite a lot
of information that has to be stored and
pushed around and it you know if you
were hoping for the sort of millions of
operations per second level of
performance that at least Facebook was
getting out of memcache D the kind of
overhead that you would have to pay to
use causal consistency might be
extremely significant for the
performance so those are reasons why I'm
causal consistency maybe hasn't
currently caught on although maybe
someday it will be okay that's all I
have to say and actually starting next
lecture we'll be switching gears away
from storage and sequence of three
lectures that involve block chains so
I'll see you on Thursday
you